speaking of food in restaurants this
restaurant is celebrated from taipei
to l.a and now vegas rocky is live at
aria's newest hot spot
den tai fung where it's all about
dumplings noodles
and legacy hey rocky
hey jc yes and it's all about oh
shoot for balzai it's all about bells i
almost forgot his name
i'm so sorry my little friend okay
bowsey and albert here he's the vice
president of this beautiful
restaurant newly opened today doors open
at four o'clock right correct
oh my gosh this is a big deal for you
how does it feel to finally be opening
up in vegas
yeah it's really exciting my grandfather
started the company
in taiwan in 1972 my father opened the
first restaurant in the united states in
the year
2000 wow it was a little 60-seat
mom-and-pop restaurant and a strip mall
yeah and here we are now
on the strip and you're celebrating 20
years of being in the u.s so this is an
even bigger deal than just a grand
opening
and what can you actually expect here so
when people start walking in
it's more than just dumplings and
noodles this is this is about
legacy they're going to leave with an
experience right correct it's a
family-owned restaurant so we're very
passionate about the business
this restaurant is the biggest in
taifung in the world it's 550 seats
but with social distancing it's about
220. okay
okay and what is what will they be
eating i see i see the chefs they're
getting prepared this is a big night
they're already making some of the 10
000 that you'll make daily here
dumplings correct uh we're world famous
for our shalom bao
which is soup dumplings um each soup
dumpling has 18 folds and is weighed
at 21 grams exactly so we're really
known for our consistency
packed with meat veggies whatever you
want right yeah correct oh i'm excited
coming up in the four o'clock show i
will be tasting
some of these famous dumplings of course
i'll send it back to you
thanks rocky that looks amazing we will
check back in with you
in the four o'clock hour by the way it's
estimated that din tai fung will make as
many as 10
000 soup dumplings every day and today's
opening marks 25 years since this
restaurant first expanded
to the united states bringing dishes
from taiwan looks so good
well